this is El muttona B Street a landmark
in baghdad's city center
it's a cultural Hub and a space for
artists and activists to share opinions
these days the conversations are often
about Iraq's latest political
developments
we've learned from this year's incidents
that confrontation with the state is not
the only option to seek change we are
now regrouping with other political
activists to create a unified voice
based on National interest unfortunately
all unrest are prevailed through the
year was based on partisan interest it's
a conflict overpower
that conflict was between major Shia
political parties following the
elections in 2021
it led to the suspension of
parliamentary process and derailed the
formation of a new government
in June politicians affiliated with
influential Shia leader muktada quit
when rival parties backed by Iran
nominated Muhammad al-sudani as prime
minister so the supporters took the
streets
in August thousands stormy bardad's
heavily fortified green zone and
occupied the Parliament building holding
a city in that lasted weeks
the conflict peaked when crowds stormed
the presidential Palace
dozens of people were killed as they
were driven out of the compound by
Security Forces
other protests were staged through the
year
calls for political and economic reform
order was finally restored when the
Sudani government took office in October
scenes like this give the impression of
normality but the same issue is way
heavy on Iraqis after one year political
deadlock they finally have a government
but economic challenges and underlying
political rivalries both crucial to
ensuring stability
remain unresolved
and many are skeptical that anything
will change under the new Administration
every government breaks its promises
with the people life has become so
difficult unemployment is exacerbating
at all prices are getting higher
nepotism and Corruption are deeply
rooted in state institutions we have no
hope that a change will happen anytime
soon
the world food program said poverty
levels reached nearly 32 percent in 2020
even though Iraq is the second largest
producer of crude oil after Saudi Arabia
in the OPEC group of oil producing
countries
over the past three years many
development projects were aborted
because of political unrest now the
government and Parliament need to pass a
budget for the upcoming year as soon as
possible that would help mitigate
current economic difficulties because
the New Year's budget is estimated
around 200 billion dollars
in October authorities revealed billions
of dollars had been embezzled from State
funds and promised to recover the money
many Iraqis hope it is the beginning of
the end of government corruption